the Joe Rogan experience Instagram was
kind of dabbling with this idea of
taking away the likes right like what if
we just didn't show anyone who likes
right you don't know how many likes you
get you put up a picture it's just a
[ __ ] picture
move on yeah no you put up a picture he
got 70,000 likes for that picture what
the [ __ ] man you check it check an hour
later 74,000 oh it's going viral yes
what's weird that that likes thing is
one of the weirdest drugs nobody saw
coming and people get addicted to you
know saying things that get likes right
putting things up that are socially
conscious to let everybody know let
everybody know how virtuous you are and
exactly makes getting likes yeah and
it's it's all making use of I suppose
the the flaws of our or human nature
what I'm worried is it one day those
likes will actually be a physical
feeling oh yeah you get like a little
joke haha and though engineer the system
to get you to seek those constant love
jolts yes why not I mean if they look if
if they're gonna give you augmented
reality we are how many generations I
don't know away from something something
being embedded in your body right people
have already decided to do that there's
some was a guy or girl embedded a
[ __ ] Tesla Model 3 key their arm so
that they didn't ever have to have their
key in their pocket they could just walk
up there Tesla and the [ __ ] door
unlocks doesn't even climbing so for
updates she doesn't work anymore I
thought it runs out of batteries they
gonna cut you open like a fish just I
mean what the [ __ ] are people doing
those are people at the fringes they are
the fringes but there's more of them
than you think and if they make it more
they make it simple like you just need
like a like a flu shot but you know just
know where there is any sort of innate
fare or aversion towards you know
crossing that interior/exterior boundary
with technology there's a good way of
looking at
like what is fair is it fair if you
agree to do it look look is it fair if
you decide to get a face tattoo alright
if you if it's up to you man but if it's
fair if it's like hey man my credit card
company told me that give me 10% off if
I stick this you know this credit card
chip under my skin somewhere yes I
suppose if you instead again incentivize
it with yeah with selfish interests yeah
maybe it will take up there's that and
there's also the big concern is what if
these gentlemen we're talking about
income inequality in this world a big
one would be what if there's a jump that
you can make in enlightenment and
intelligence access to information
number-crunching the ability to assess
risk versus reward this is all done
computer wise and it's it's done through
some sort of additional piece of
hardware that they give you or and put
in your body but it costs a lot of money
so the people that can afford it
initially are the people that are
valuable they have money in the first
place they're the wealthy people already
because it's very valuable but then the
people that really need it they can't
afford it
so by the time it becomes something ever
all the money's gone everybody's chewed
it all up everybody's figured out how to
hack the system you should become a
writer for a black mirror that seems
like a black mare episode it seems like
it would work right yeah that's well
that's what people are worried about
when it comes to longevity too right
they're worried about technological
innovations and are allowed people to
you know nanobots and all sorts of
different weird things gonna repair
cells and allow them to live for
extended periods of time but then who
are these people going to be are they
gonna be the king class you know they're
gonna be this super duper wealthy people
of the future that are gonna you know
hold this over the poor folks you can't
afford the technology yeah yeah so it
truly seems like the the technologies
that we're developing were that at least
are not too far away our institutions
aren't ready yet
- - recopa does know because definitely
that would be prolly increase inequality
quite a lot yes that that is one of the
major concerns when it comes to this
sort of rapid change that we're facing
right now and you know another one of
course is artificial intelligence
there's there's people that I respect
very very much that have a very negative
view of what the future of artificial
technology is gonna mean to the human
race Maris elan alone yeah both of them
scared the [ __ ] out of me every time I
talk about it yeah Sam Sam Sam and I did
an episode and I where he talked about
artificial intelligence and the rise of
in the fact that once it's uncorked it's
really not going to be able to be put
back in the bottle
yeah and we talked about for like an
hour and a half and after it was over
like the rest of day I was bummed out
sure I was like this is inevitable yes
so the person I have a very I suppose a
very optimistic and pessimistic view of
technology at the same time I think on
one hand it allows us to to improve the
world and that's what we seem and it's
it's gradual and it continues probably
because people want to solve their own
problems and with that inadvertently
solve other people's problems that's
progress happens I believe but then at
the same time while the world is getting
a lot better it's also getting riskier I
mean two thousand years ago or maybe
even two hundred years ago there was no
way to wipe out humanity that simply
wasn't if you even if you wanted to to
happen very badly you know you could
scream wouldn't happen now though there
are actually people who have the power
to do that and rapidly like you could
the whole of humanity could be wiped out
in a day yeah and now it's fortunate
just a few people would imagine if that
goes from a few people to quite a few
corporations to maybe right even
everyone I think there's a there's this
this sort of brain teaser or mental
experiment that
boström came up with that says well what
if you could have kind of this atomic
bomb that you could just make yourself
in your microwave it's like well maybe
at some point in time we would just not
be economically feasible anymore to
rebuild cities because I don't know it's
on one hand you know and so I think
that's kind of the this this the scary
you know risky aspect of it but at the
same time when you think of it I would
much rather trust or end trust and an
average person today with the button for
a nuclear detonation detonation device
then somebody a thousand years ago
oh for sure I'm one of the Mongols or
someone some Savage
[Applause]